hi everyone this is professor m dust
science and today we're going to solve
the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian of the hydrogen atom in
another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the proton and the
electron in the hydrogen atom interact
via an electrostatic potential their
interaction is described via a
differential equation the eigenvalue
equation of the hamiltonian to
understand the properties of hydrogen we
need to solve that equation and
calculate the energy eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions and that is precisely the
plan for today's video the solution is
rather interesting and it takes the form
of a power series today we're going to
focus on the mathematical solution and i
have to confess that it is rather long
but i promise you that it is worth doing
it at least once while today's focus is
on the maths i really encourage you to
check out the other videos in the
hydrogen atom series to get a more
conceptual understanding of the system
so let's go
let's think about the hydrogen atom
hydrogen is made of two particles a
proton and an electron
in the introductory video on the
hydrogen atom linked in the description
we discuss how the important physical
content of the system is encoded by the
relative motion of the proton and the
electron
this means that we can describe the
hydrogen atom using an effective one
particle relative hamiltonian which has
a kinetic energy term and a potential
energy term
for the full details about this relative
hamiltonian check out the introductory
video on the hydrogen atom but in short
mu here is the reduced mass of the
system and is related to the individual
masses of the proton and electron by
this equation
p here is the relative momentum given by
this expression in terms of the
individual momentum of the proton and
electron
and r here is the relative precision
given by the distance between the proton
and electron positions
the hamiltonian is the key to
understanding the hydrogen atom using
quantum mechanics and the aim of this
video is to describe the mathematical
solution of its eigenvalue equation
in particular we're going to consider
this problem in the position
representation so we can rewrite the
relative hamiltonian as equal to the
kinetic energy term in the position
representation
plus the potential energy term in the
position representation
an important observation is that the
potential of this system is essential
potential
we have a full series of videos where we
discuss the general properties of
central potentials and today we will
exploit many results from those videos
in solving the hamiltonian eigenvalue
equation for hydrogen so i encourage you
to check them out if you haven't yet
for completeness we can also write down
the relative hamiltonian by spelling out
the kinetic energy term in spherical
coordinates and as discussed in the
video on central potentials it is given
by this prefactor
multiplied by a term that involves the
derivative of r
and then a long term that involves the
derivatives of the angular variables
and finally don't forget the potential
energy term
but before we start with the maths two
additional points
we discuss in the introductory video on
the hydrogen atom how the large mass
difference between the proton and the
electron means that the relative motion
of the two particles is such that the
proton is almost at the center of mass
and therefore the relative motion is
very close to the motion of the electron
about the proton
this insight is very useful to help us
conceptually understand hydrogen and it
is useful to think of this relative
hamiltonian as simply describing the
motion of an electron in an
electrostatic potential generated by a
stationary proton
the mass of course still describes the
true relative motion of the two
particles
second to simplify notation from now on
we're going to drop the rel sub index
here and simply write h for the relative
hamiltonian
using this hamiltonian we can build its
eigenvalue equation like this in this
equation these are the eigenvalues and
these are the eigenfunctions
in the videos on central potentials we
learned that the hamiltonian of
essential potential commutes with the
orbital angular momentum operators
this implies that the eigenfunctions of
the hamiltonian can be chosen to also be
eigenfunctions of the squared orbital
angular momentum
and eigenfunctions of the z component of
orbital angular momentum
remember that in the l squared
eigenvalue here l can only take
non-negative integer values
and that for the lz eigenvalue here
and for a given l
ml can only take one of these values
separated by integer steps
if you need a refresher about orbital
angular momentum you can find all the
relevant videos in the description
another important result from the videos
on central potentials is that the common
eigenfunctions can be labeled by three
quantum numbers k l and ml
l and ml are the quantum numbers
associated with orbital angular momentum
and k describes the energy spectrum for
a given l and ml
the energy eigenvalues can be labeled
with k and l but they don't depend on
the ml quantum number
another important observation
from those same videos is that these
three equations imply that the common
eigenfunction psi is a product of a
function r that only depends on the
radial coordinate and another function y
that only depends on the angular
coordinates these functions y are called
spherical harmonics and are labeled by
the angular momentum quantum numbers l
and nr
for more on these spherical harmonics we
have a video dedicated exclusively to
them and the link is in the description
what we care about today is that the
spherical harmonics are the same for any
central potential
this means that we've already solved
half the problem before we've even
started because the angular part of the
eigenfunctions of the hydrogen atom is
given simply by the spherical harmonics
this other part here is called the
radial part of the eigenfunction and it
depends on the quantum numbers k and l
but it does not depend on ml
this radio part is the most interesting
part because its form depends on the
specific central potential that we have
and therefore the aim of today's video
is to determine this radial function for
the specific example of the hydrogen
atom
the strategy we'll follow for the
solution is actually very similar to the
one we use in another central potential
problem the 3d isotropic quantum
harmonic oscillator so i would recommend
that you check out that video for
another example of solving eigenvalue
equations of hamiltonians that describe
central potentials
so our mission for the rest of this
video is simply to determine the radial
part of the eigenfunctions
as we learn in the videos on central
potentials the radial function obeys the
radial equation
this equation has a term that involves
derivatives in the coordinate r a term
that depends on the l quantum number
and the central potential which in our
case is the electrostatic potential
all acting on the radial function
and equal to the energy eigenvalue
multiplying the radial function
the energy eigenvalues here and the
radial functions here only depend on the
k and l quantum numbers
this is the first step of our solution
as we already know the angular
dependence of psi we can reduce the full
eigenvalue equation for psi to this new
differential equation that will allow us
to determine the radial part
the first step is one that is common to
the solution of every single central
potential
it is convenient to make a change of
variables such that the rate of function
is equal to one over r times the new
function u
we can then rewrite the radial equation
for the function u as given by this very
long operator
acting on the u function
and equal to the eigenvalue times the u
function
what is the point of this change of
variables the equation for u is simpler
than the original equation for r because
this differential operator here has a
simpler form than the original one up
there
but this equation is not enough to
ensure that we get physically valid
solutions we need a boundary condition
on u such that when we evaluate it at
the origin we get zero
this discussion so far is the same for
any central potential and we're not
going through every single step in
detail because we've already done so in
the videos linked in the description
today we will actually solve this
differential equation to determine the
form of u for the hydrogen atom and once
we have u we can use it to calculate the
radial part of the energy eigenfunctions
from this relation up here
before we actually tackle this
differential equation we need to discuss
two additional topics
this time here looks like the kinetic
energy of a particle moving in the one
dimension labeled by the direction r
we can also combine the l dependent term
with the electrostatic potential and
collectively call them an effective
potential
as we discuss in the video on the radial
equation of central potentials this now
looks like the eigenvalue equation of
the hamiltonian of a particle moving in
1d and subject to this effective
potential
while we know that in reality we have a
3d system and that the true potential is
simply the electrostatic potential here
this effective view provides a useful
tool to understand the problem
one of the convenient features we gain
by treating this as a 1d problem is that
we can easily visualize it on a pair of
axes
we have the coordinate r along the
horizontal axis and the true potential
along the vertical axis yielding this
diagram
we can then plot the effective potential
for the different values of l trivially
getting the original potential when l
equals zero
this effective potential when l equals
one
this one for l equals two
and we would get similar shapes for the
effective potential for all other values
of l
now what's important for our purposes
today is that all of these potentials
asymptotically approach 0 from below as
r increases here
building on from the videos on bound and
unbound quantum states we know that this
type of potential leads to two types of
solutions for the eigenvalues and
eigenstates of the hydrogen atom
for positive energies say somewhere here
the motion of a classical particle
moving in these potentials is unbounded
as for large r the potential tends to
zero
in this situation for a quantum particle
we get what are called unbound states
the corresponding energy spectrum of a
quantum particle is continuous
and the corresponding eigenfunctions are
not square integrable as they do not
vanish for large
r by contrast for negative energies say
somewhere here
the motion of a classical particle
moving in these potentials is bounded as
the particle's energy is lower than the
potential at large r correspondingly we
get bound quantum states
this leads to a discrete energy spectrum
for a quantum particle
with associated square integrable
eigenfunctions that vanish as r becomes
large
the focus of our video today will be to
find the spectrum of the bound states of
the hydrogen atom so we will exclusively
focus on negative energy eigenvalues
and a final step before we solve the
differential equation with the aim of
simplifying notation
first let's define a new quantity a0
equal to 4 pi epsilon 0 h bar squared
over mu e squared
a0 is called the reduced ball radius and
you should check that it has units of
length
for our purposes today this is a purely
pragmatic definition that will allow us
to simplify notation but as we study the
hydrogen atom we will see that the
length a0 actually has an important
physical meaning because it is a measure
of the typical atomic dimension
second let's define another quantity e
sub i as equal to mu over two h bar
squared multiplying e squared over four
pi epsilon zero all squared
e sub i is called the ionization energy
and you should check that it does indeed
have units of energy
again today we will simply treat this as
useful definition
but e sub i also has an important
physical meaning it is the energy needed
to unbind an electron in the ground
state of a hydrogen atom
we're now going to use these definitions
to simplify the differential equation at
the top
first let's multiply both sides of the
differential equation by this term
moving down here we obtain this new
derivative term
this new l dependent term
this new potential term
and we're also moving the eigenvalue to
this side of the equation
all acting on u
and all equal to zero
i have rewritten some of these terms in
a form that will prove convenient in a
moment
so feel free to pause here and cross
check this step
moving on we now see that this term here
is a zero squared
this term here is also a zero squared
this term here is a zero and this term
here is the inverse of e i
this means that we can rewrite the
differential equation in a much simpler
form
we first have this differential term
then the l dependent term then the
potential term and then the energy
eigenvalue term
all acting on u
and everything is equal to zero
note that in this latest expression i've
also multiplied by minus for convenience
and a final simplification let's define
rho as equal to r over a naught
and lambda as equal to the square root
of minus the eigenvalue over e sub i
at fast size this minus sign here may
look strange but remember that we are
looking for energy eigenfunctions of the
hydrogen atom that correspond to bound
states and bound states have negative
energy eigenvalues
therefore the argument of the square
root is overall positive making lambda a
real quantity
with these definitions we can now
rewrite the differential equation in
terms of rho and lambda like
this and feel free to pause here to
double check this change
and now i hope you will agree that it's
been worth making these changes as this
latest expression for the differential
equation is very compact which will
prove helpful when doing the maths
conceptually though what we've done is
to simply use the reduced bore radius
here as a unit of length and the
ionization energy here as a unit of
energy
to solve this differential equation we
first consider its asymptotic behavior
in the limit of rho going to infinity
in this limit we have that this constant
term dominates over this term that has
row in the denominator and over this
term that has rho squared in the
denominator
this means that in this limit we can
approximate the full differential
equation as containing the derivative
term and the constant term all acting on
the function u and all equal to zero
we've ended up with a standard second
order linear homogeneous differential
equation and the two solutions for you
are this positive exponential and this
negative exponential
if you aren't convinced feel free to
plug in these solutions into the
differential equation to confirm that
they are indeed the solutions
these two solutions are of course
not the full solution of the problem
because we're neglecting two terms in
the differential equation
however this analysis tells us that the
solutions in the limit of large row
behave like exponentials and this is an
important insight because of the two
solutions only the negative exponential
here is in fact a physically acceptable
solution
this is because the other solution
diverges for lunch row and would lead to
solutions that cannot be normalized
so how can we use this knowledge
going back to the full range of allowed
valleys of rho we can now draw
inspiration from the asymptotic behavior
and write the true u function as equal
to the negative exponential times a new
function v
and what do we accomplish with this
change
we know that the solution must behave
like a decaying exponential in the limit
of large row so by singling it out here
we are hoping that this will lead to
simpler maths and indeed we're going to
find that this is the case
but before we go on note that by
singling out the negative exponential we
haven't actually removed the unphysical
positive exponential solution so we will
still have to deal with that later on
okay so let's next rewrite the
differential equation with this latest
change
remember that the function u is equal to
this exponential times the new function
v the harder term is the derivative here
so let's write the second derivative of
the new expression in terms of v
using the chain rule we first get the
term involving the second derivative of
the exponential multiplying the v
function
then the cross term which is two times
the first derivative of the first term
times the first derivative of the second
term
and finally the time involving the
exponential and the second derivative of
v
the second derivative of the exponential
with respect to rho easily evaluates to
this
and the first derivative of the
exponential with respect to rho easily
evaluates to this
putting everything together we start
with the exponential common factor
then considering this first term up here
we get a time proportional to the
function v
from this middle term up here we get a
term proportional to the first
derivative of v
and from this final term up here we get
a term proportional to the second
derivative of v
we are now ready to rewrite the
differential equation up here in terms
of the v function
first we can use this expression we just
calculated to replace the second
derivative term all the way up here
doing so we end up with the common
exponential factor
and we then copy the long expression we
just derived
going back to the full differential
equation we then have the l dependent
term then the term arising from the
electrostatic potential and the term
arising from the energy eigenvalue all
acting on v and or equal to zero
finally we can remove the common
exponential factor as we are equating to
zero
and we can also cancel this lambda
squared here with this one here
overall we end up with the second
derivative term the first derivative
term
and these two terms that don't involve
derivatives
all acting on v
and or equal to zero
so solving this differential equation
will give us the function v but we need
an extra ingredient remember that we had
a boundary condition for the function u
such that it vanishes at the origin
as u and v are related by this
expression
we can straight away conclude that we
get an analogous boundary condition for
v
before we launch into the final push for
the solution let's recap where we're at
solving this equation we'll find the
function v that depends on rho once
we've got v we will be able to build u
using this relation between the two
and also going back from row to r using
this relation
and once we've got u we'll be able to
calculate the radial function r using
this relation between the two
finally once we've got the radial
function we will be able to construct
the full eigenfunction psi using the
standard separation in terms of radial
and angular paths
this may look like a rather convoluted
path to determine the eigenfunctions but
they obey a rather complex differential
equation to start with so we had no
reason to expect a straightforward
solution
okay so we're now ready for the final
push let's figure out what v is
we will write v as a power series
we set it equal to rho to the paras
and then a power series in row
we can also rewrite it by taking the
power s inside the sum
without loss of generality we start the
sum at q equals 0 which means that we
choose c0 to be the lowest non-zero
expansion coefficient so that the lowest
power in the expansion is this s here
this choice will not affect the final
answer but it's a convenient way to
write the power series
let's first look at the derivative terms
for the first derivative of v we can
rewrite it as the derivative of the
power series
and as the derivative is a linear
operation we can simply calculate the
derivative of each term in the sum to
get this new sum
for the second derivative of v we have
that it is equal to the first derivative
of this expression we've just derived
and we again evaluate the derivative of
each term in this series to get this
other series
we now have all necessary ingredients to
rewrite the differential equation at the
top in terms of the power series
every term will have the summation over
the c coefficients so we can start with
that
we then have the second derivative term
at the top here which is given by the
second derivative of the power series
we've just derived
moving to the second term at the top
here we have this pre-factor and then
the first derivative of the power series
and moving to the next two terms up here
gives this expression
times the power series
and finally all of this is equal to zero
let's briefly recap
starting with the differential equation
for v at the top here we have then
expanded v as a power series in rho as
shown here
and this is the expression we get for
the differential equation when plugging
in the expansion of v to simplify this
further we can combine this factor of
rho squared with this power over here to
get a power of q plus s minus 2
and we can also combine this factor of
row in the denominator here with this
power over here to get a power of q plus
s
minus 1.
we can then rewrite the whole expression
with the same sum over c q
and then creeping together the q plus s
minus two powers
and then the q plus s minus one powers
and all is still equal to zero
feel free to pause here to make sure of
this step but all we've literally done
is to rearrange the terms
next we consider the boundary condition
at the top here
writing v as a pass series we can impose
the boundary condition by evaluating it
at the origin and then setting it to
zero
so how can we ensure that this equation
holds
we must have that s is strictly larger
than zero
otherwise we would get a constant
non-zero term in the sum that wouldn't
vanish at the origin
so putting everything together the power
series expansion coefficients must obey
this equation at the top and the
boundary condition implies that s is
positive
the only way in which a full power
series can equal zero is if the
coefficients in front of every single
power vanish
now inconveniently in the expression
that we have here every term contains
two different powers q plus s minus two
here and q plus s minus one here
this means that we need some extra work
to clearly identify the coefficients in
front of each power and to see what's
going on let's consider the first few
powers explicitly
to simplify notation i will call this
first term aq
and this second term b q
let's start with the lowest power in the
series s minus two
the term proportional to the a
coefficient here gives a power of s
minus two when q equals zero which means
that we end up with this term
proportional 2 c 0
for the term proportional to the b
coefficient here the lowest power in
this term is s minus 1 so it doesn't
make a contribution to the s minus 2
power
as the coefficients of each power must
vanish then these coefficients of the
power s minus two must be equal to zero
the next power is s minus one
the a term gets a power of s minus one
when q is equal to one and we have this
term proportional to c one
now the b term does contribute with its
lowest power corresponding to q equals
zero and giving this term proportional
to c zero
so this is the full coefficient in front
of the power s minus one and it must
also vanish
we could go on like this term by term
and the general power q plus s minus 2
has contributions from the a term
proportional to c q and from the b term
proportional to c q minus 1. and again
these coefficients must vanish
what do we learn from this set of
equations
we can solve them to determine the
expansion coefficients of the v function
written as a power series
so this is what we need to do
let's start with the first one
corresponding to the power s minus 2.
so this is the first equation that the
expansion coefficient must obey
using this expression up here for a sub
q we can write down
eight naught explicitly by setting q
equal to zero and we get s times s minus
one minus l times l plus one
we can now insert this expression for a
not into the equation up here and we get
c zero multiplying the expression we
just got for a naught and all equal to
zero
remember that by definition c zero is
the first non-zero coefficient
which means that this bracket must
vanish to obey this equation
in principle there are two possible
solutions either s is equal to minus l
or s
is equal to
l plus one
however we've established earlier that
the boundary condition that forces the
function v to vanish at the origin
implies that s must be strictly larger
than zero
combined with the fact that the quantum
number l is non-negative
then these two results together mean
that the first solution up here is not
consistent with the boundary condition
as a result the only valid solution is
s equal to l plus one
and this result fixes this
going back to our set of equations we're
now ready to look at the general power q
plus s minus 2.
we have to use this equation here
and we start with c q
then we use the expression for a up here
to write down its value at aq
then we add c
q minus one
and use the expression for b here to
write down the expression for b q minus
one
and all this equal to zero
we've just shown that s equals l plus
one and using this expression for s here
here
and here we end up with this term
proportional to the cq coefficient
and with this term proportional to the c
q minus one coefficient and all equal to
zero
we can now take this bracket
proportional to c
and we copy it down
multiplying the first two brackets
through we get these four terms
and we also have to subtract the final l
times l plus one term
we can now cancel this term with this
term and we end up with a common q
factor multiplying q
plus two l plus one
and feel free to pause here to double
check this step
bringing everything together we end up
with this long expression that describes
a recurrence relation between the cq
and the c q minus one expansion
coefficients
let's recap
we're trying to solve this differential
equation up here subject to this
boundary condition on the right
we have postulated a solution in the
form of a power series like this and
we've now concluded that the expansion
coefficients in this past series must
obey this recurrence relation between cq
and cq minus 1 where i've somewhat
rearranged the expression we got in the
previous slide
remember also that c0 is different from
zero by definition
what this means is that starting from a
general expansion coefficient cq
we will be able to use the recurrence
relation to end up writing it as
proportional to c zero we won't do this
just now as it will be easier to do
after we've determined the possible
values of lambda here
but as we can in principle do this for
any expansion coefficient we will be
able to write the full path series in
terms of the c naught expansion
coefficient
finally we will be able to fix c naught
itself by normalizing the resulting wave
function
the next question that we explore is
whether the series is finite or infinite
mathematically we can have both options
but we will see in a moment that only a
finite series gives physically valid
solutions that can be normalized
to explore this question of
normalization we will first suppose that
we have an infinite series
to be absolutely clear remember that we
are considering the series expansion of
the v function like this
in this case we can take the limit of
large q for the ratio of c q over c
q minus 1.
using this expression up here the
dominant term in the numerator is 2
lambda q and the dominant term in the
denominator is q squared
simplifying we end up with 2 lambda over
q
what does this mean if we have an
infinite series then for very large q
the ratio of consecutive coefficients
tends to this value
let's hold this thought and we will come
back to it in a moment but first we need
an extra ingredient
to understand the implications of the
limit we just discussed we will now show
that it is the same limit as that of a
rather simple function that we can
easily analyze
let's consider the past series expansion
of this exponential
we can write the exponential as this sum
over q
of the usual power expansion for an
exponential
and for convenience we're going to
rewrite it as the sum over q of an
expansion coefficient day q
times the power where we identify a q
with the original expansion coefficient
we can now calculate the ratio of a q
over a q minus one
plugging in this definition we get this
for the numerator
and this with the denominator
the two power is simplified to two
lambda
and the two factorial terms simplify to
q in the denominator
in the limit of large q we end up with
the same ratio we had on the previous
slide
right let's go back to our series
expansion for the function v
we've just established that if we
consider this exponential as a power
series then the limit of large q for the
ratio of consecutive expansion
coefficients is equal to this expression
now these two expansions are slightly
different because this power of s here
in the first expansion is not present in
the expansion of the exponential
however all this extra power s does is
to provide a shift in the comparison of
the expansion coefficients between the
two series and such a shift becomes
irrelevant in the limit of q tending to
infinity
overall this means that both series have
the same limit for large q
and in turn this means that if our
serious expansion for v is infinite then
the v function behaves like this
exponential for higher order terms in
the expansion
and this is where we have a problem this
exponential has a positive argument here
so it becomes increasingly large for
large role
this means that this v is a physically
unacceptable solution because the
resulting wave function would not be
normalizable
and therefore the key question becomes
how can we avoid this unphysical
solution for v
and of course the answer is that
physically relevant solutions correspond
to past series with a finite number of
terms
before we explore what that means a
quick aside having an infinite series is
a mathematically valid solution that
leads to the physically invalid solution
we already found when we solved the
differential equation in the limit of
large r
but now it is appearing for the full
equation
so we need to ensure that this power
series is finite
to do so all we need is to find an
expansion coefficient term say the kth
expansion coefficient
such that c k vanishes
given the recurrence relation up here
this immediately implies that all higher
expansion coefficients also vanish
and the series becomes finite as
required
so the question now is how can we ensure
that ck vanishes
this will happen if the numerator up
here is equal to zero when q equals k
explicitly the series will terminate if
lambda times k plus l minus one
is equal to zero
rearranging we get that lambda is equal
to one over k plus l
at this point it is important to note
that i've conveniently labeled by k this
integer index at which the series
terminates
this is because this is a number we can
use to label the different eigenvalues
for a given l and we had already decided
to call this quantum number k so i am
now using this label
finally
remember from earlier in the video that
we defined lambda kl as equal to the
square root of minus the energy
eigenvalues ekl divided by the
ionization energy e i
rearranging we get that the energy
eigenvalues are equal to minus ei times
lambda squared
and using the result we just found for
lambda up here and inserting it in this
expression we get minus e i over k plus
l squared
also remember that l is a non-negative
integer and as c zero must be different
from zero as shown up here this means
that k must be strictly larger than zero
and
this implies that the allowed values of
k
are positive integers
so
by insisting that the series must be
finite
we have now come to a key result
the energy eigenvalues of the bound
states of the hydrogen atom are
quantized and the energy levels are
given by this expression
now this is a hugely important result
but we won't explore it any further
today as we're only focusing on the
maths however you can check out the
videos that we have linked in the
description and they have a lot more
information and discussion on these
energy eigenvalues
we're now ready to go back to our
recurrence relation and determine the
values of the expansion coefficients in
terms of the first coefficient c0
to do so we're first going to simplify
the expression we have for the
recurrence relation by inserting this
value of lambda
inside this expression
doing so we get the ratio of cq to cq
minus 1 as equal to this numerator where
i am already inserting the value we have
for lambda
over this denominator
if we now focus on this term in the
numerator we can copy it down
we can then combine the two terms to get
this
we can now cancel the l here with the
one here and end up with this expression
going back to the recurrence relation at
the top we can rewrite it like this
where i am doing some trivial
rearrangement
and this is the simple recurrence
relation that we will use moving forward
let's start by copying the recurrence
relation where i am moving the c q minus
1 factor to the right as it will prove
convenient in a moment
next we want to use the recurrence
relation again but now write c q minus 1
as equal to the corresponding fraction
times c q minus two
do you pause here to double check this
step all we've done is to replace q by q
minus one
inserting this expression inside the one
above we first get the q independent
terms which now appear to the power 2
and then this long expression with the q
dependent terms
times c q minus 2.
this now gives us a relation between c q
here and c q minus 2 here
and we now play the same game again and
again until we arrive at c q
equal to the power q of the q
independent terms
then this very long expression involving
the q dependent terms
and all multiplying c0
and again feel free to pause here to
make sure of this latest expression
which may require you writing out a few
more terms explicitly before it clicks
the final step is to first pick this
term in the numerator here which we can
rewrite to this expression in terms of a
ratio of factorials this term in the
denominator which is simply q factorial
and this other term in the denominator
which again we can rewrite in terms of
another ratio of factorials
this allows us to write the final
expression for c q as equal to minus 1
to the power q multiplying 2 over k plus
l all to the power q
multiplying these two fractions
involving factorials
and all multiplying c0
and finally we have a general expansion
coefficient cq in terms of c0
and that's it
after this incredibly long and
mathematical derivation we now have all
the ingredients that we need to study
the energy eigenvalues here and
eigenfunctions here of the bound states
of the hydrogen atom
so we'll now finish with a brief summary
of the key results which we then use in
other videos to explore from a more
physical perspective the meaning of the
eigenvalues and eigenfunctions
so the full eigenfunction psi is equal
to the product of a radial part and an
angular part
the angular part is given by the
spherical harmonics because the
hamiltonian of the hydrogen atom
commutes with the orbital angular
momentum operators
the radial part is the trickier part to
determine and we've done just that in
this video by solving a rather complex
differential equation
doing so has required a large number of
steps
first we've rewritten the radial
function in terms of a new function u
like this
we've then made a change of variables to
rewrite u
as a function of a new variable rho
where rho is the ratio of r and the
reduced bohr radius
then by considering the limit of large
rho we've defined yet another function v
which is related to the u function via
this relation and where lambda is
defined as equal to the square root of
minus the eigenvalue over the ionization
energy
next we've expressed the function v in a
power series like this where the
exponent s is equal to l plus one
and finally we've shown that the
expansion coefficient cq is related to
the expansion coefficient c0 by this
rather long expression
we can then complete the solution by
fixing c0 through normalizing the wave
function
and this is it this is all we need to
determine the eigenfunctions once we've
determined these c expansion
coefficients we can construct v once we
have v we can construct u in terms of
the row variable we can then go back to
the original coordinate r
and once we have u like this we can
construct the radial function and once
we have r we can finally build the
eigenfunctions
with this recipe we can now build any
eigenfunction we want and you can find
examples of this in the videos linked in
the description
okay so if you've made it this far
know that this is our longest video so
far so thank you for sticking around i
encourage you to check out the rest of
the videos on the hydrogen atom series
to gain a more conceptual understanding
of the mathematical solution that we've
derived today and as always if you liked
the video please subscribe